♪♪
NARRATOR:
Medieval France.
A time that ushered in a new era
of nobility.
Have another guard kill that
one.
Yes, sire.
I'm sorry, who?
Kill him.
No, I couldn't my lord. I have
known Arnaud my entire life. We
came up together as squires.
Would it be easier if we got a
third guard to come in and kill
both of these guys?
Oh whoops, here we go.
Agh!
Ahhh!
Good work.
(Sigh)
Quasi! Quasi! Quasi!
Holy shit.
Come on, we're going to be late.
♪♪
You know what your problem is?
Is it that I've got a fatty
deposit the size of a giant
gourd on my back?
Weirdo!
Freak!
-Hunchback.
-Morning!
♪♪
Ah, the royal torture chamber.
Back to the daily grind.
Ughh!
You guys psyched for Pope Week?
Oh my God, here we go. Another
Pope Week.
Pope Week. I love Pope Week.
Who wants to see an exorcism?!
(Crowd cheers)
Welcome to the Papal lottery.
HENRI-FRANÇOISE:
Winner of the lottery shall have
his private
confession heard by
the Pope himself.
Quasi, you won.
A hunchback, no! Do you have any
idea the questions he’ll have
for me?
Holy Father, can you fix my
hump? Is not my very existence
proof there is no God?
I don’t want to get into that
whole hornet’s nest.
Quasi, Quasi, Quasi!
Are you going to ask for a new
back?
Oh yeah, like a tall back maybe?
Or perhaps a new face?
No mom would like that face.
It'd be like put it back in my
vagina.
Okay.
NARRATOR:
On 4/20,
in a tale of love.
I very much like your rack.
And I, yours.
NARRATOR:
Betrayal.
And Scandal.
Quasi, these are actual
depictions of the Pope having
sex with Saracen women.
Oh mon dieu! Is that mud?
It’s not mud. It’s not mud.
NARRATOR:
Everyone plays a part.
Or two.
♪♪
Send a warning shot. Shoot over
their heads.
Yes, my lord.
Michel!
Whoops!
I said shoot over their heads.
I’m not even sure that that was
my arrow.
I saw it come out of your
crossbow.
You know what, that was
Gregor’s. Gregor!